face off in the ring to the right of McKenzie
Blackwood sharks have been outshot in all 14
games they have played thus far this season as
Anaheim wins the draw Lao get shot tipped in Frank
patrono has number 10 Anaheim leades one nothing
simple play it it starts with an offensive zone
Faceoff win quick little wrist shot by lausin
we talked about Mason McTavish being better in
the faceof circle this year and boy when you win
draws in the offensive zone quite often and you
at least get a puck towards the net not much
Blackwood can do about that the shots coming
in waist high or slightly above that and Frank
patrono gets a Nifty little touch on it zerland
turns it the other way and then Carlson Steals
on the back check here comes Leo cuts it front
big save Blackwood and he covers off surprising to
People John that was not the scouting report that
it was a huge strength of Carlson but man what an
effort just to tuck that puck inside covering the
slot and his backhand will clear the Zone that's
good shift for San Jose they get Pucks in deep
it's their fourth line was out there against the
Carlson line hurdle a nice pass across shot went
off a skate hurdle got the rebound and they score
cunan was there and he got the loose change this
game is TI yeah they they caught a tired Ducks
line trapped on the ice defending for a while
and doing an okay job of it but then San Jose
was able to get fresh players over the boards
kind of a broken play thrown towards the net
and eventually just swatted into the back of
the net by Luke cunan rebound went off of Gibson
popped up in the air there's a good look at it
from this angle and you can see that cunan
just gets the shaft of the stick knocks it
right out of midair Mason McTavish to take the
draw to the right of McKenzie Blackwood and he's
able to control it fower activates cross
pass oh the is robbed by Blackwood oh good
[Music] stop still over a minute of power
play time for Anaheim and they win the
faceof Carlson off the right wing half wall
little deflection came right to color tried
to stuff it in McKenzie covers up out of a
broken play Carlson again loves that shot
pass there's the redirect it didn't end up
on going on net and and it's another Faceoff
win enri gets it back from Fowler high slot
Let It Go just wide silverberg battling for
it down low got it back to vrono high
in the zone fer vrono one time Frank
[Music] two one timer Bender not set this
time I I like when power plays shoot early
that's what Adam Henrik did it gets all the
Defenders running around a little bit and boy
Frank vrono just stepped into it that may have
touched vasic just a little bit well boy that's
up into the top corner and nothing the Blackwood
can do about that blast let's go Ducks is the
chant as banan's shot blocked on the way by
Addison down to the final minute and here's a
two-on-one hurdle for the Sharks on a big save
by Gibson John Gibson catches a little piece of
his hip and then bounces out the and followed
up by Leo Carlson across the line he hands it off
Terry finds Fowler coming late into the zone right
back to Troy he'll churn across the top of the
slot from the dot hit the goal post oh that was
vintage B but let's go back to this move by Troy
Terry and I was mentioning about him on his edges
John this is what Troy Terry does look at look
at how quickly his feet are moving and he rele
spinning away from Kyle Burrows from behind the
net turns tried to get it into the slot in here's
color big save with the right pad by Blackwood oh
great stop Blackwood again watch him just hang on
head up all the way and then he kind of muscles it
into the middle Lauren boy had the goal tender he
had room over top of that right leg just couldn't
quite elevate it enough the Ducks set a SE jackob
gets it back once more as he works the right
boards and mikov gets it from leushin popping
out High Henrik his shot leaves a rebound right
there oh oh what a save by McKenzie Blackwood
into the boards there's the scoring chance I was
just talking about pass off the mark McTavish has
has to turn to receive it off the board mikov to
Terry in front cologne got a stick on Blackwood
couldn't cover it up and it's taken back by Terry
tries once more and it's broken up by Burrows who
clears and Gibson races 35 ft out of his net to
head man the puck Carlson mov jumps in big save
Blackwood oh what a good read there on a look out
now out of the box granin Breakaway Gibson punch
es it away with the blocker he still got it to the
front of the net though on the second effort mov
further to the head and Leon gets it in Carrick
is there steps right into the goal crease loose
to the right of Blackwood who covers [Applause]
up middle of the ice minakov Terry will try one
timer kicked all the way back out to the line
by Blackwood minakov going to switch places now
with McTavish Carlson back to McTavish he's
scores wonderful little twom man game 3-1
[Music] andah Mavish up top gives it to Carlson
he looks one way but just delivers a strike I
mean this is just a perfect pass and a beautiful
finish for Mason McTavish you want to talk about
the future of the Ducks how about this goal
McTavish from Carlson and mov left side peels
back and his little pass controlled by vrono
Frank did well to pull that one back now pops
out High open at the right point is Gus he'll
Wind and Fire off of San Jose stick scored it
floated in the air and Blackwood never picked
it up and it floated in the net ran K goodas
has his second of the Year boy lot a lot
of guys wouldn't have played it this way
there there it's way up in the are you
see Blackwood he has no idea he's down
goenda Hoffman that came out to try and block
the shot and my goodness classic treding to jump
which is hard to do with skates on Frank
doesn't have a shooting Lane either he's
pressured by Sturm and does a nice job to keep
it in backhander from Henrik in and out of the
glove of Blackwood Adam has it again around Oran
stro stro curls off the left boards hangs on to
it Fowler winds fires wide off the boards oh
it went off the Stick of silverberg nice job
by vrono to keep it alive into the middle now
Henrik lays it off for Fowler vrono leans into
it another good save by Blackwood yeah those are
two good shots good stops fending off stop on
the initial one and boy the second one's even
better with the kick indirect off the boards
Henrik to a streaking Carrick down the slot
excuse me with Max Jones and now silverberg
freees it up back for Jones in the slot oh off of
Blackwood just wide scw hits the breakes wants to
tra places with gutus instead he turns it over
Breakaway for cunan Luke cunan turned away by
Gibson and Gru gets it back to Center ice and
now into the San Jose zone for Leon in the
corner a minute 15 left the Ducks are that
close to ending a mini two game skid Fowler
got up to the net hit by Gru save Blackwood
who holds his ground and eventually covers up
yeah as there's a little frus in front
of the Anaheim bench the horn sounds
the Ducks win at home for the second
time this year by three goals or more